[Musique]
c'est à l'aéroport de
Vélizy-Villacoublay dans les Yvelines
que le journaliste Olivier Dubois retenu
en otage pendant 711 jours au Sahel à
atterri ce midi le président Emmanuel
Macron est venu l'accueillir sur les
lieux le journaliste indépendant
correspondant de libération du point et
Jeanne Afrique avait été enlevé à Gao
dans le nord du Mali où il était venu
interviewer un cadre d'un groupe armé
djihadiste il a été libéré hier lundi 20
mars la réforme des retraites a été
adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale lundi
20 mars après le rejet des deux motions
de censure mais la mobilisation ne
faiblit pas pour autant dans les
Yvelines ce matin une manifestation
avait lieu à Élancourt à l'initiative
des syndicats CGT et CFDT près de 200
personnes se sont retrouvées devant
l'entreprise Thales plusieurs employés
ont rejoint le mouvement le cortège est
ensuite dirigé vers les entreprises
Airbus et CRMA une deuxième
manifestation aura lieu au départ de la
gare de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines jeudi
23 mars à 10h et une manifestation au
flambeau au départ de
encore transport sont les missions qui
pourront être donnés pendant les jeux
les conditions d'inscription sont
simples avoir 18 ans au 1er janvier 2024
par les le français et où l'anglais et
être disponible au moins 10 jours on
termine par du sport en football dans le
championnat de National inversailles
paire de précieux points dans la course
à la première place sur le terrain du
Mans les joueurs de la cité royale n'ont
pas trouvé la faille et n'ont pas pu
faire mieux que match nul 0 à 0
conséquence aux classement Martigues
s'empare de la place de leader avec un
point d'avance sur Versailles prochain
match pour le FC Versailles ce vendredi
sur le terrain de Cholet
[Musique]